have a question for David Cameron
because he's just said to all of us that
he wants to stay the course because
that's not what the Conservative Party
want to do at all remarkably the
Conservative Party have said they're not
going to ask the richest in society to
make a single extra penny a contribution
to balancing the books through the tax
system they want to impose ideologically
driven cuts on schools that I can I just
I when I hear the Conservatives talk
about a choice between competence and
chaos just imagine David Cameron the
chaos in people's lives the people who
in the NHS don't know where they're
going to find the money the people who
don't know where their nursery or their
college or their schools are going to
close that's why Johnny's right you need
to take a balanced approach you do need
to reduce spending but you also need to
ask the richest to make a contribution
it's the only fair way of finishing the
job well Nick is wrong about our plans
because of course we are going to raise
five billion from tax evasion and
aggressive tax avoidance as we've done
in this Parliament that's part of the
balanced plan that also involves putting
more money into our NHS and cutting
taxes you're not wealthy wealthy but
very well think you've some of the tax
avoiders
and evaders but here's the point we've
got to understand why the deficit
matters and why we got here and the
problem and the real choice is with Ed
Miliband who still thinks the last
Labour government didn't tax too much
borrowed too much and spend too much and
if you don't understand the mistakes of
the past you can't provide the
leadership for the future
Everland I